how's it going bros minds oh we're
playing shrek extra-large this is
actually a game like I thought this was
a fan made game you're about to see what
I'm talking about let's press Start yep
my name oh alright well we're playing
with that then what a wonderful loading
screen have a guy change your view Jesus
shrek calm the [ __ ] down
this is my favorite trick game of all
the time and play it every week hey
chicken how you doing this is what you
get for being a [ __ ] chicken kids are
so lucky with the games they get did the
sound effects for Shrek
yeah Michigan I need to check your anus
that's a one beautiful booty hole [ __ ]
you what what there you go anyway I
could do this all day
nice nice very nice check shrek when he
blazes it it goes from - oh nice of
course I love this game already this is
my new favorite game and OH makings like
these anymore do they
I check out I love yo chicken what are
you going o chicken chicken hey that I
love you son Oh meet you in the combat
arena he's gonna [ __ ] mazing me alright
I'm ready
good work okay i fingered his [ __ ]
this can't be a real game who published
this to fill your gas meter some of
those onions there we go
nice verb flames Jesus
who came up with this Oh came up with
this I hope his ass like that there we
go
oh boy anyone who bought this game sure
is how it won't be disappointed oh this
is my house this is my swamp alright
we're in this forest
game over I just sit down and cry what a
bunch of bullies to bridge alright
sounds good to me I named you so ugly
what the [ __ ] do you want from me you
want cookies Jesus Christ you [ __ ]
perps stop molesting me what did they
stop look look woody wait stop stop
please sir please please I'm Shrek I'll
get right it's all good right stop stop
god damn all right let's find them it's
a [ __ ] kick you loose
I can't aah what what is that
get the bag Jesus I don't know where
your [ __ ] cookies is God whoever made
this game just loves camp wrangle
something date what what happened oh I
literally collect an easter egg Wow eyes
a leopard way there we go yes that's how
bridges work fabulous fabulous ah for
[ __ ] sake that [ __ ] [ __ ] head shot
at me Jesus Christ do I have to do
everything again oh yes I love it gate
the lake I'm Shrek okay we did it again
can't wait to see what's on the other
side
Oh what the [ __ ] what rich
what is happening chicken how did you
even get here
sorry chicken I love you oh yes the blue
fat fairy's I remember those from the
movie what you gonna do about it now huh
it's gonna dance for me sucking on my
titties like you wanted me calling me
all the time that
check out my cushy bunny oh yes go crazy
oh yeah that's just how I like it that's
right that's where the cookies are just
dig a little deeper little deeper and
you got it oh sorry
my favorite game of all time ha that's
what I intended to do all along [ __ ]
you guys want some [ __ ] cookies
follow me I just follow me all right
be careful he's really locked in on my
ass he's like no no no my ass no is that
so go don't leo this is working actually
holy [ __ ] you see that giant [ __ ]
cookie thing nope
my ass is not Mike you [ __ ] kidding
me
stop stop damn it
Jesus Christ she's [ __ ] pushing me
off stop pushing stop pushing me I swear
to god damn it did he oh my god
all right you're right you want the
[ __ ] cookies then follow me
don't push me Oh God Oh God they [ __ ]
push me don't make me [ __ ] put a
cookie up your ass stop stop stop
Oh God we're [ __ ] no I'm just gonna
have to assume that they're following me
yes get shrekt get it Wow yes alright
stay [ __ ] me close or I'll [ __ ]
murder you
look let's cookies oh god it's done oh
thank god thank God oh my god what are
they doing in there what do they ate her
house you ungrateful son of a [ __ ] shut
up don't hump the cookies alright now
you've taken it too far where are you
going buddy hi [ __ ] get slick gets leg
let's see if I can drown him
oh it's not water I don't understand why
this [ __ ] doesn't [ __ ] work and why
is there a [ __ ] chicken there why not
I watched I would I watched a [ __ ]
walkthrough I got it I got it just gotta
make it that cam Josh get shocked oh
that was so hard
what do we got is that our basket oh yes
we had that [ __ ] - looking at it alright
we have to kill a girl holy [ __ ] look at
much money I have
why don't I just take all this money and
run away maybe I could even afford some
plastic surgery do something about this
god-awful face
I made it white for Michael Jackson get
shrink or die trying
that's the candy what a lovely sound
when you get a heart so you [ __ ] eats
the heart out or some [ __ ] oh god what
was that
ah what is happening Shrek what are you
doing - out of time there we go
I don't remember where the rest is
dammit alright
yes I think we got another one shut up
I'm not smelly ogre I wear the One
Direction perfume alright
where's the last piece of candy Paradis
I remember now yes oh yeah we don't even
need to give her the basket it just
teleports what a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my god
mother Goose Island can't wait oh god is
that is that it's what when he said
break it down it to me straight
shrinks your tree
[Music]
[ __ ] sweep listen to this shape no
Gabe put me down and I'll get me down
you know have you not seen my MLG
montage this bra [ __ ] see this [ __ ] I
know okay I [ __ ] love a Trekkie
I love it - Shrek I love it - you want a
chicken girl you want to take in a white
you want it come get it what are you
doing those are my chickens and only I
can kick them or sheep what am i doing
fixing it or some che hell man Shrek
alright friends I can play this all day
but I gotta end it there I hope you
always enjoyed this episode if you did
hit the like and it's the sky convert
today I see brows and the next one yeah